Hagamos algunos ejemplos comparando valores
absolutos. Imagina que nos piden comparar el
valor absoluto de 9 negativo con el valor absoluto
de 7 negativo, así que pensemos un poco en esto,
y pensemos en cómo se ve el 9 negativo o en
dónde está en la recta numérica y dónde está
el 7 negativo en la recta numérica. Veamos
qué significan los valores absolutos y luego
probablemente podremos hacer esta comparación.
Así que hay un par de formas de pensar en esto.
Una es que puedes dibujarlos en la recta numérica,
entonces, si esto es 0 este es 7 negativo y aquí
está el 9 negativo. Ahora, cuando tomas el valor
absoluto de un número, realmente estás diciendo
qué tan lejos está ese número del 0, no importa si
es a la izquierda o a la derecha de 0. Entonces,
por ejemplo, 9 negativo está 9 a la izquierda de
0, por lo que el valor absoluto de 9 negativo es
exactamente 9. Esto se evalúa como 9; 7 negativo
está 7 a la izquierda de 0, por lo que el valor
absoluto de 7 negativo es 7 positivo. Así que
si tuvieras que comparar 9 y 7 esto es un poco
más sencillo: 9 es claramente mayor que 7. Y si
alguna vez te confundes con los símbolos mayor
que [>] o menor que [<], recuerda que el símbolo
es más grande en el lado izquierdo, así que ese
es el lado mayor que. Si tuviera que escribir
esto, y eso también es un enunciado verdadero,
si los tomo sin los signos de valor absoluto, es
verdadero que 9 negativo es menor que 7 negativo.
Observa que el lado más pequeño del símbolo señala
el número más pequeño, y eso es lo interesante:
9 negativo es menor que 7 negativo, pero dado
que 9 negativo está más alejado de 0, el valor
absoluto de 9 negativo que es 9 es mayor que el
valor absoluto de 7 negativo. Otra forma de pensar
en esto es que el valor absoluto de un número en
realidad será la versión positiva de ese número,
por lo que el valor absoluto de 9 es igual a 9,
y el valor absoluto de -9 también es igual a 9.
Bueno, al visualizarlo podemos darnos cuenta de
que es porque ambos números están exactamente a 9
posiciones del 0: esto está en 9 a la derecha de
0 y este está en 9 a la izquierda de 0. Hagamos
algunos ejemplos más. Digamos que queremos
comparar el valor absoluto de 2 con el valor
absoluto de 3. Bueno, el valor absoluto de un
número positivo será el mismo valor: 2 está dos a
la derecha de 0, por lo que esto se evaluará como
2, y luego el valor absoluto de 3 se evalúa como
3. En realidad es bastante sencillo. Entonces
2 es claramente el número más pequeño aquí,
y entonces obtenemos que 2 es menor que 3, o
el valor absoluto de 2 es menor que el valor
absoluto de 3. Así que aquí tenemos un símbolo
de menor que. Digamos que quieres comparar el
valor absoluto de 8 negativo con el valor absoluto
de 8. Bueno, una forma de pensar en esto es que
ambos están a 8 posiciones del 0: este 8 está a la
izquierda del 0 y este 8 está a la derecha del 0,
así que ambos se evalúan como 8, el valor absoluto
de 8 negativo es 8, el valor absoluto de 8 es 8,
y así claramente 8 es igual a 8. Permíteme hacer
un ejemplo más. Digamos que quiero comparar el
valor absoluto de 1 negativo con 2 positivo,
entonces el valor absoluto de 1 negativo es
sólo la versión positiva de 1 negativo, que
es 1, así que 1 es claramente menor que 2,
o dicho de otra forma, el valor absoluto
de 1 negativo es claramente menor que 2.